well everybody welcome to drew's news
your all-you-can-eat news buffet full of
fresh good news-itarian options
and with me at the desk a true buffet
connoisseur ross matthews
[Applause]
[Music]
what's your number one buffet tip ross
well i like that you can go all the way
around the world you can have egg roll
and spaghetti all in one place thank you
buffets i have missed you i i will make
you fall in love with buffets drew i
promise i'm the man to do it i got the
elastic pants and ready to go all right
let's dig into our extra special edition
of food
talking about yeah next frontier and
food there's a food innovation that you
can try out right now just across the
river in jersey city fox business
reports that the newport center mall has
just installed a hamburger vending
machine
it's called roboburger
and it cooks up fresh burgers made to
order in just six minutes the robot
grills your patty toasts your bun and
then squirts your burger with some
condiments
ross yes
thought well you know there are
inventions where you always remember
where you were the first time you heard
about them this is one of those
inventions robo burger welcome to the
family and i say this is somebody who
worked at mcdonald's i talk about it
proudly here i know how to assemble a
hamburger triple threat triple threat
register drive through and grill thank
you very much
and so i'm watching that were you guys
watching that robo do its thing on there
i like your technique robo you know how
to make a burger i would eat one of
these they so imagine this it's like
frozen patties in there they're grilling
them to your specifications how you want
it would you try a robo burger i would i
like and i like burgers occasionally and
i like veggie burgers so i hope they
have both options because i'm a super
flexitarian yeah what's next i think
there's going to be a robo taco i mean
i mean it's endless wait a minute why
can't we have like robo baked potato bar
you're a
you're a genius drew barrymore
do you remember the jetsons and we're
always like when are we going to live in
that time well welcome to the future
everybody that's right rossi all right
well now we've got a unique dining
experience that could be coming to a
city near you other than roboburger good
news network reports you can now get a
gourmet meal cooked over hot molten lava
now if you like hibachi but wish it was
just more extreme than this meal is for
you it was created by bumpus and par an
innovative food group out of london and
they hosted the first lava dinner in an
ancient canyon in saudi arabia they know
how to do it fancy
guests ate steaks and fish charred over
fresh hot lava where you even get lava i
don't know but you know the degree that
lava is it's like
2462 degrees fahrenheit that's hot i
know what they had for dessert chocolate
lava cake hello i'll be perfect
perfect
has anyone here ever like deep fried a
turkey
raise your hand if you have this one
over here you did right in the shirt
right here right here in the front oh my
gosh
may i ask what your name is laurie
lori
how did it go when you deep fried a
turkey well my ex-husband did it but it
was really good i always wanted to
attempt the um
fried turkey and the hot oil but all i
ever heard was like how you know people
can like lose finger i mean it's like so
dangerous
um and and i'm scared and yet i really
want to try it because god i'll eat a
shoe that's been deep fried for sure
what about next but i'm scared and and
this this
gives me the lava i'm like i need a
panic attack medicine yeah how who's
who's it's slinging lava
around like the deep-fried turkeys this
takes it way too far
would you try it the lava no i never
even tried the deep-fried turkey because
i'm too scared oh i would totally try
the lava and i just have to say next
thanksgiving we should get a deep fryer
and a turkey because i'll get in gobble
gobble i'll get in there drew let's do
it what do you think should i try it yes
yes
maybe you'll come back for where do you
live boston that's not far no
maybe you can always come back for
thanksgiving and we could have a uh
are you single yes me too
awesome so we could have a single ladies
like
uh turkey fry
[Applause]
annual single ladies turkey fry it's on
[Music]
you